[Music]
[Applause]
i mentioned that chris mannix said back
in april that uh you know the boston
sort of boston basically out coached uh
he got out coached in the series against
the boston celtics and i wondered and i
even said this to manix i've said it to
you know woad like why does kevin durant
won out and then we found out after
meeting with the brooklyn nets owner
that he doesn't want to play for steve
nash and the gm sean marks we bring in
chris mannix sports illustrated nba
senior writer
mannix how did we get to this point
where now it's he doesn't want to play
for steve nash who he hand-picked to be
his head coach in brooklyn
yeah um
it obviously was a
combination of things that happened over
the course of this year because
if you're kevin durant i mean you did
sign a four-year max level contract
extension
just
last fall and you committed to playing
for steve nash to playing
for sean mark so
i can't say specifically dan it was one
thing
that pushed kevin durant to this point
but it probably had a lot to do with how
the roster was put together it probably
had a lot to do with how the james
harden situation was handled and it
certainly had something to do with how
the season ended with kevin durant um
you know are with the nets being soundly
beaten by the celtics and as i wrote as
you said outcoached
uh by imei udoka in that series so i
don't think it's one thing but i think
it was it has been a combination of
things and this
you know in delivering this message
you know kevin durant has probably wiped
away any chance you bring him back like
this is now out there
that he doesn't want to play
for steve nash or play
under sean marks i don't know how
there's any going back from this okay
who leaks this what side leaks this who
who benefits from this being out there
i can't imagine kevin durant did like
this does not feel like something kevin
durant would want out there or his team
would want out there
it feels to me and it's more speculation
of course
but it feels to me like this is
something the nets put out there to
effectively call durant's bluff to say
look because like within hours after
that report
leaking out
josiah is tweeting i support the
coaching staff he wasn't i mean when is
the last time you saw an owner
effectively verify a report like i've
never even heard of anything like that
so
um this to me felt like something the
nets put out there to call durant's
bluff and
now i it feels like i was talking to
somebody that's been in contact with him
that's yesterday it feels like both
sides right now are going to dig in like
the nets are not going to let this
lower their asking price and they're
probably gonna dare kevin durant
not to come to training camp in the fall
and
do what ben simmons did and that doesn't
feel like something kevin durant wants
to do
how does this play out
again it kind of you know all this is is
new information
but
it does still feel like we're in the
same place where
we have to see what the nets appetite is
for going to training camp with this
group i mean i had one executive who was
not involved in the durant talks text me
and say look they should just take the
boston offer because jaylen brown is
better than anybody they're going to get
in a deal it's not going to be what they
wanted
but it will net them a 25 year old
all-star wing who's under contract for
the next couple of years so
again i don't know what brooklyn's
appetite is
to go into next season or going to
training camp with you know this roster
currently attacked and i've said this to
you before dan like after the initial
boston stuff broke and everything else
like this is now a game of chicken where
teams are going to wait and see how the
nets feel in late august early september
and if the nets are still
resolved in their asking price for
durant maybe those offers go a little
bit up if the next contact teams say
look we'll do it instead for this
those offers uh will probably stay the
same
any chance steve nash is not the head
coach of the brooklyn nets next year
or this season i think there's a chance
i think there's a chance i mean
look i i've been critical of steve nash
you just said it like i i don't i
thought steve nash was the bizarre
choice two years ago
i think he's a bizarre choice now like
it was thinking outside the box when
there was no need to think outside the
box i mean steve
has been dealt a tough hand over the
last couple of years with the kova
issues and certainly last year with
kyrie but
he has no history of coaching like his
coaching before then
was effectively parachuting in
to golden state and working with kevin
durant you know a couple of days a month
that's not the kind of coach you want
for
a championship level team i mean
it takes coaches a long time to learn
how to be great i mean jason kidd's a
great example jason kidd is one of the
upper echelon coaches right now but he
had to be awful in brooklyn and mediocre
in milwaukee before he got to this level
steve nash if he wants to be a great
coach he's probably gonna have to go
through that same
type of process i just thought the nets
smart everybody by bringing in a great
player and steve nash is tough to
criticize for a lot of people because
he's such a great guy but
you only had to watch four games
in that boston series to know that he
wasn't an elite coach imei odoka coached
circles around him in that series so
i do i do that's a long way of saying i
do think there's a chance that steve
nash is not the coach of this team next
year how does any of this impact kyrie
irving
you know that it's
they are kind of on two separate tracks
here in a way i know they've been
interconnected with the nets are gonna
wait to
see what happens with kevin durant
before moving off kyrie irving
i've always felt that if the nets get
the offer they want for kyrie that
brings them back a quality player and
doesn't force them to take on more
salary than they're giving up because of
luxury tax concerns that they would do
it um that offer is not materialized at
this point the lakers as far as i know
are still the only team in the nba
eager to take on kyrie irving because it
would get them off russell westbrook
the nets don't want westbrook there's
not a third team that's willing to
facilitate this deal at this point that
could certainly change in the next few
weeks to a month but right now um
there's just nothing out there for kyrie
irving either
great stuff chris thanks for joining us
on short notice we appreciate it as
always
you got it dad that's chris mannix
sports illustrated nba senior writer